[Musique]
l'hebdo politique bonsoir et bienvenue
dans l'hebdo politique votre rendez vous
du dimanche soir sur radio sensations en
association avec tv 78 épisodes 215 mon
invité ce soir et le président d'agir en
essonne louis leroy
[Musique]
les politiques
lui le roi bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
donc le président du mouvement agir la
droite constructive en essonne et vous
êtes conseiller municipal d'opposition à
orsay revenons un peu en arrière d'abord
agir et c'est un mouvement qui est né
après l'élection présidentielle
d'emmanuel macron en 2017 fondée par
franck riester actuels ministres agir
rassembler les républicains qui
souhaitait donc dépasser le clivage
gauche droite avec donc emmanuel macron
alors certains ont dit que c'était de
l'opportunisme politique d'autres y ont
vu un certain courage de pour dépasser
est allé au delà des convictions vous
qu'est ce qui vous a fait adhérer à ce
mouvement alors je pense que vous avez
tout dit au début de votre question
parti s'appelle agir la droite
constructive on était des élus des
personnes engagées dans les différentes
villes dans les différents départements
dans les différentes régions de france
qui avons dit au lendemain de l'élection
d' emmanuel macron nous voulons faire
avancer le pays nous voulons voir nos
valeurs représentées celles d'une droite
qui se veut humanisme d'humaniste celles
d'une droite qui se veut européennes
celles d'une droite qui se veut sociale
celle d'une droite qui vient parler de
culture franck reister et ministre de la
culture comme vous l'avez dit il est
aujourd'hui au commerce extérieur c'est
une véritable volonté de vouloir faire
avancer le pays en fait qui nous a
motivés pendant vingt ans la gauche la
droite ont rêvé de réformes que le
président de la république en fait j'ai
été mais très très très surpris pendant
ces cinq dernières années de voir ce
cynisme politique sur les bancs tant à
gauche qu'à droite du parlement ou dans
les débats de de réformes que qu'ils
avaient rêvé qu'ils avaient imaginé que
le président actuel a mis en place et
qui pourtant
voté contre ce sont
vraiment
révolté dans les médias alors que ces
réformes c'est lé l'heure d'aujourd'hui
agir c'est une composante de la majorité
présidentielle aux côtés de la
république en marche du modem mais aussi
territoire de progrès ou encore du plus
récemment du nouveau parti horizon alors
justement vous former ce que vous
appelez avec eux donc une maison commune
avec tous ces partis pas toujours simple
de suivre agir et horizons souhaitait
d'ailleurs fusionné récemment finalement
emmanuel macron s'est opposé pour le
moment mais qu'est ce que vous avez
pensé de tout ça est est ce que agira à
vocation à devenir a fusionné avec
horizons dans les années à venir c'est
une maison commune une maison commune
dans une maison commune c'est la famille
on peut être d'accord sur certains
sujets on peut des fois avoir des points
de
divergence mais à la fin ça reste une
maison commune avec toutes ses
composantes et tous ceux qui veulent
faire avancer le pays et tous ceux qui
veulent soutenir le président de la
république agir et horizons devaient
fusionner ça c'est pas passé est ce
qu'il faut aller parler aujourd'hui de
tambouille politique en pleine campagne
présidentielle alors que la crise
sanitaire est pas encore tout à fait
derrière nous alors que on connaît des
difficultés aujourd'hui économique pour
avoir un grand nombre de citoyens du
pays je suis pas certain que c'est là
que nous attendait nos électeurs et nos
habitants dans nos communes donc je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on doit avancer
sous la même bannière la bagna elle
s'appelle ensemble citoyens ça réunit
agir à droite constructif sa réunion
horizons ça réunit territoire de progrès
le modem en marche l'idée c'est qu'on
avance ensemble autour d'une
problématique commune autour d'un
programme commun celui du président de
la république donc justement nous allons
revenir maintenant à l'actualité de ces
derniers jours à commencer par la fin du
port du masque dans les lieux clos
soumis aux passes vaccinale la mesure
sera en vigueur au 28 février le lundi
28 février prochain il était temps d'un
soupir enfin les restrictions ça fait du
bien ça fait du bien au moral les boîtes
de nuit ont ouvert dans l'est ces
derniers jours ça fait du bien de voir
un petit peu ce retour à une vie quasi
normale pour autant l'épidémie elle
existe encore je lisais récemment le
l'interview de monsieur del fra si le
président du conseil scientifique dans
les médias je sais pas si il était temps
de le faire je pense qu'il est temps de
le faire parce que les conditions sont
réunies pour qu'on puisse tout doucement
retrouver un semblant de vie normale à
titre personnel comme beaucoup je pense
que je m'en réjouis ça veut dire que ça
va mieux ça veut dire que la tension
dans les hôpitaux est moins grande ça
veut dire que le virus circule moins ça
veut dire que la vaccination d'un très
grand nombre de deux deux citoyens
fonctionne donc je pense qu'on peut que
ce que se réjouir que ça arrive à ce
moment sur la question de la question du
timing beaucoup l'opposition regrette
que comme par hasard ça arrive juste
avant l'élection présidentielle vous
qu'est-ce que vous pensent que c'est les
décisions qui sont pas politiques c'est
les décisions qui sont médicales qui
sont prises par un conseil scientifique
par des médecins au mois d'août
personnel je suis pas médecin quand le
président du conseil scientifique dit il
est temps nous pouvons retirer les
masques j'ai tendance à faire confiance
au plus tôt à la science et aux médecins
plutôt qu aux commentateurs politiques
qui parlent de à longueur de journée sur
les plaques dont des gardes et des
situations dans d'autres pays notamment
si oui mais en l'occurrence le pays
c'est la france et on regarde ce qui se
passe dans les hôpitaux français on
regarde ce qui se passe dans nos villes
et nos villages et on voit
qu'aujourd'hui l'épidémie est en train
de freiner est en train de ralentir et
on peut retrouver un semblant de vie
normale en tout cas on peut aller dans
cette direction voilà maintenant comme
ça j'écoute l'avis des médecins j'écoute
l'avis des scientifiques et ceux dont
c'est le métier plus que ceux des
observateurs et des commentateurs le
prix du carburant ne diminue pas et
atteint des records le gouvernement
refuse d' abaisser la tva sur l'essence
une mesure réclamée par les oppositions
la bataille pour le pouvoir d'achat sera
un des enjeux de la présidentielle la
majorité ne risque-t-elle pas de se
mettre certains une bonne partie des
français à dos en refusant restant sur
cette position le problème du du coût du
carburant du prix de l'essence c'est au
delà de ça le prix de l'énergie en
général c'est pas un problème français
est ce un problème qu'on observe dans
toute l'europe qui est dû au cours du
pétrole qui est dû au cours du dollar
qui est lui à plein de deux
caractéristiques au delà des taxes donc
qu'on peut pas ramener le problème juste
à la tva ou différentes taxes sur le
carburant mais oui je suis d'accord je
pense que pouvoir d'achat va être une
question centrale de la campagne si ce
n'est la question centrale on parle
beaucoup j'entends sur les plateaux télé
parler d'immigration parler de deux
d'assimilation que sais-je je pense que
le véritable problème aujourd'hui des
français c'est comment boucler la fin du
moins ça a été un quinquennat sur lequel
il ya des efforts qui ont été faits
alors faudra sans doute aller plus loin
le mieux étant l'ennemi du bien on est
tous unanimes pour dire ça mais je crois
que la bataille du pouvoir d'achat sera
la bataille de la présidentielle et le
gouvernement d'ailleurs a mis en place
la prime
d'inflation de 100 euros qui a concerné
quand même 38 millions de foyers c'est
l'équivalent quasiment de 10 plein
d'essence faire la différence sur 10
plein d'essence je pense que c'est un
effort significatif qui est fait il ya
eu beaucoup de mesures pendant le
quinquennat qui ont permis aussi de
gagner du pouvoir d'achat j'entends que
c'est jamais assez j'entends qu'on peut
toujours aller plus loin c'est pour ça
que cinq ans de plus seront pas de trop
pour poursuivre les réformes qui ont
déjà été entreprises et regarder ça avec
humilité je pense que tout n'a pas été
réussi bien qu' il ya eu quand même des
avancées majeures pour le pouvoir
d'achat pendant ce quinquennat cinq
années de plus et on pourra aller plus
loin j'aimerais à présent parler avec
vous de la jeunesse qui a
particulièrement été touchée par la
crise sanitaire insertion plus compliqué
sur le marché du travail d angoisse pour
l'avenir sur les retraites sur les
enjeux climatiques notamment à 24 ans
vous faites partie aussi de cette
génération de jeunes qui ont affronté le
coc vide comment est ce que vous l'avez
vécu personnellement est ce que vous
êtes optimiste vous pour la suite
de l'histoire moi je les ai vécus le
premier confinement plutôt mal comme
tout le monde on s'est retrouvé enfermé
on ne savait pas trop ce qui se passait
et donc comme toutes les générations qui
la met à une époque ma génération
d'ailleurs je pense toutes les
générations confondues le président de
la république avait dit c'est pas facile
d'avoir 20 en 2020 ce qui était vrai je
pense que c'est forcément très évident
non plus d'en avoir soixante dix où 80
de vivre l'isolément et j'ai beaucoup
pensé à ce moment là d'ailleurs aux
personnes isolées aux personnes seules
et c'est vrai que les étudiants qui
souvent loin de leurs familles se sont
retrouvés dans cette situation
excessivement bizarre à ce moment là
c'était très compliqué maintenant là
encore il ya eu énormément de fait j'ai
souvenir du repas
universitaire à 1 euro les deux repas
dans la journée il ya eu ensuite les
chèques pour pouvoir consulter un
psychologue parce que c'est vrai que cet
enfermement 7 cet isolement et compliqué
il ya cette phrase de la fontaine que
j'aime beaucoup dans une fable qui dit
la raison n'habitent pas longtemps chez
les gens confiné c'est vrai il y avait
de quoi devenir fou au bout d'un moment
mais c'était un devoir de solidarité
c'était un devoir on était tous dans le
même bateau et on essayait tous deux
s'en sortir donc il ya des choses qui
ont été faites et c'est vrai que vous
parliez d'insertion des jeunes on a
quand même l'a été sur le quinquennat
qui était celui qui a signé quasiment
700 milles contrat d'apprentissage en a
jamais eu autant corps qui est un record
malgré la crise sanitaire on a un taux
de chômage qui est au plus bas depuis 15
ans dans le pays donc il ya eu des
choses de faites pour les jeunes il ya
une là encore des choses sans doute
qu'ils n'ont pas toujours
réussi mais je pense que dans l'ensemble
on peut dire qu'on n'a pas laissé les
jeunes sur le carreau la politique du
gouvernement qui a proposé un jeune une
solution elle a marché là encore une
fois on fait pas de politique on fait du
factuel est ce qu'aujourd'hui un jeune
qui se connecte sur la plateforme peut
demain déboucher un emploi un stage un
contrat d'apprentissage et la réponse
c'est oui et bien aussi à partir du 1er
mars le contrat engagement jeunes qu'ils
absolument qu'il sera mis en place et on
peut parler également du pass culture à
hauteur de 500 euros qui a été versée ou
les jeunes ont pu consommer de la
culture que ce soit bon c'était
compliqué pendant la crise qu'ovide bien
sûr mais ils pouvaient acheter que ce
soit des livres des bd aujourd'hui des
places de spectacle des disques ou ce
genre de choses je trouve que ça va dans
le bon sens aujourd'hui dans la campagne
présidentielle les candidats de droite
comme de gauche essaye de séduire un
maximum de jeunes une catégorie qui
s'abstient énormément d'habitude à
gauche l'idée d'un revenu minimum
jeunesse et est évoquée par plusieurs
candidats aux arènes on propose
d'exonérer d'impôt sur le revenu les
jeunes de moins de 30 ans d'autres
proposent de re évalué les bourses de 25
% ou encore dark d'accorder des prêts à
taux zéro pour les jeunes en sortie
d'études que pensez vous de toutes ces
propositions qui sont sur la table
aujourd'hui dans le débat de la
présidentielle je pense qu'on est
finalement assez loin des réelles
problématiques et des véritables
desiderata de cette génération cette
génération aujourd'hui elle demande pas
grand chose elle demande à pouvoir avoir
un parcours universitaire ou
un parcours technologique ou
professionnelle qui demain débouchera
sur un emploi et de pouvoir vivre
dignement de son travail c'est là encore
on y revient on parlait d'un jeune une
solution la plateforme qui a été mis en
place par le gouvernement on parle des
700 mille contrats d'apprentissage on
parle de cette revalorisation
2 du pouvoir d'achat chez les étudiants
qui doit être au coeur de la campagne et
edu et du futur quinquennat à venir je
crois que c'est il est là l'enjeu
l'enjeu c'est l'emploi pour la jeunesse
aujourd'hui c'est pas de savoir si
est-ce qu'il faut exonérer d'impôt pour
une plupart à la plupart des jeunes qui
n'en payent déjà pas c'est pas savoir
s'il faut faire un revenu universel vous
savez je crois que les jeunes ils n'ont
pas envie d'être perfusé ils n'ont pas
envie qu'on les prenne par la main ils
n'ont pas envie d'être sous la tutelle
entre guillemets de l'état ils veulent
pouvoir vivre tout simplement dignement
de leur travail d'arriver sur le marché
de l'emploi et qu'on leur dise pas mais
monsieur vous n'avez pas d'expérience où
il faut travailler ailleurs avance il
est là aujourd'hui le véritable combat
c'est l'emploi c'est l'insertion
finalement les mesures proposées se
savait juste à cacher le problème non je
lancerai des mesures qui sont
électoraliste mais qui sont finalement
assez loin des enjeux de la jeunesse je
crois pas qu'on soit là dedans je crois
pas que la jeunesse est en vie ou et
besoin qu'on lui dise ce sera un crédit
à taux zéro ou ce sera ce genre de
choses en fait les gens veulent des
choses très simples simplement vivre
dignement de leur travail de ce qu'ils
font à la fin de la journée aux
dernières élections régionales et
départementales 80 2 % des moins de 35
ans se sont abstenus et ne sont pas
allés voter à gauche plusieurs candidats
proposent d'instaurer le droit de vote à
16 ans pour les jeunes pour lutter
justement contre l'abstention l'idée
revient sur la table régulièrement au
cours des différents quinquennat vous
qui vous êtes engagé très jeune en
politique justement ce que vous pensez
que ce serait une bonne chose ou pas ce
droit de vote à 16 ans je vois pas ce
que ça apporte de plus un jeune qui va
pas voter à 18 ans je vois pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils iraient voter à à 16 ans
pour moi là encore une fois on touche
pas le bon problème je suis pas certain
qu'à 16 ans une majorité de jeunes aussi
soit suffisamment intéressés ou engagés
dans la vie
de tous les jours des voitures pourrait
peut-être assez matures alors après
c'est pas forcément une forme de partage
des gens c'est ça dépend leur part je
pense que le problème est pas là je
pense qu'aujourd'hui à toute une
génération qui se désintéressent de la
politique parce que toute une génération
de politiques les à désintéresser de la
de la chose publique aujourd'hui il faut
redonner confiance il faut redonner
confiance il faut redonner de l'espoir
et moi je crois une seule chose c'est
l'effet c'est les résultats aujourd'hui
on peut je pense mettre tous les
protocoles en place de
2,2 pour leur expliquer qu'il faut aller
voter pour leur expliquer que c'est un
acte citoyen si on leur donne pas
confiance si on leur donne pas l'envié
si on leur donne pas envie de se
projeter dans le monde de demain puisque
c'est aussi ça c'est la question de se
dire bon bah je suis d'accord avec telle
mesure je suis d'accord avec telle
mesure mais concrètement dans dix ans
dans 20 ans dans trente ans dans 40 ans
on va où c'est ça aussi la question que
se pose la génération qui est la nôtre
d'ailleurs c'est de dire dans quel monde
demain vivront nos enfants dans quel
monde après demain vivront nos
petits-enfants quelle terre on veut leur
laisser quelle société on veut leur
laisser on peut parler d'environnement
on peut parler d'économie on peut parler
de retraite on peut parler de la
sécurité sociale tous ces grands toutes
ces grandes problématiques et
aujourd'hui voilà trouve pas forcément
de réponses dans le débat public
pour le coup il ya une phrase d'edouard
philippe que j'aime bien c'est voir loin
pour faire bien je croise à jean le
quinquennat emmanuel macron a lancé le
service national universel
le sn il s'adresse à tous les français
âgés entre 15 et 17 ans pour le moment
seuls cinquante mille jeunes peuvent s'y
porter volontaire pour l'édition 2022
elle a commencé cette semaine d'ailleurs
donc il vient ensuite une mission
d'intérêt général voilà pour la première
phase vient séjour de cohésion qui
suivit d'une mission d'intérêt général
en première phrase qui peut ensuite être
poursuivi par un engagement plus long
comme un service civique par exemple que
pensez vous de cette démarche a
notamment une tribune de plus d'une
centaine de maires qui l'ont soutenu
c'est seulement je trouve que c'est une
excellente initiative je trouve que ce
service national il est là pour
évidemment refédérer autour des valeurs
républicaines qui sont les nôtres il est
là pour fédérer des jeunes entre eux qui
parfois avec des parcours scolaires qui
pouvait être
difficile il a pour but de faire sens on
est une société qui pour moi ne manque
de liant pour moi manque de cohésion ce
service national universel il à cette
vocation la serre et engager les jeunes
autour des grandes valeurs de la
république et je trouve que c'est une
très bonne initiative et moi je serai
totalement pour qu'il soit généralisé on
en a quelques-uns en essonne ndour
danger notamment en tête c'est une très
bonne chose il faut poursuivre dans
cette voie là qu'est la voie de
l'engagement on parlait tout à l'heure
du fait se désintéresser d'aller voter
le chemin du bureau de vote c'est aussi
le chemin des valeurs de la république
et de la fierté d'appartenir à cette
belle et grande nation qu'est la france
il faut redonner l'envié et redonner le
goût
d'avoir envie de se projeter dans un
pays de savoir ce qu'on peut faire pour
lui de savoir comment on travaillera
demain comment se déplacera demain
comment est-ce qu'on se respectera
demain à l'heure où tous ces mots sont
un petit peu floue un petit peu
compliqué à anticiper pour beaucoup
avant de parler avec vous les chemins
local j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur la
campagne présidentielle actuellement
d'un côté il n'a jamais eu autant de
candidats autant de possibilités de
propositions mais de l'autre pourtant on
a l'impression que les français
finalement ne se désintéresse de cette
campagne alors comment est ce que vous
vous l'expliquer je la trouve triste
cette campagne je les trouve triste
franchement je trouve que le débat est
pas au niveau je trouve que quand je
regarde des candidats que ce soit les
candidats de la gauche les candidats de
la droite les candidats de l'extrême
gauche les candidats de l'extrême droite
je trouve qu'elle manque de souffle je
trouve qu'elle manque de propositions je
trouve que personne parle de demain je
les vois tous parlé de commenter les
sondages chaque semaine chaque jour
pierre a doublé jacques jacques a
redoublé pierre c'est pas là qu'on nous
attend c'est pas là qu'on nous attend je
pense qu'il ya un choix aujourd'hui qui
est le choix de la sécurité dans les
yeux c'est le choix du président de la
république parce que les gens jugent sur
un bilan le président la république
parle pas de lui à chaque à chaque
passage le gouvernement parle pas de lui
à chaque passage il est sur le terrain
il travaille et jusqu'au dernier moment
il travaillera et je pense que c'est la
bonne stratégie à tenir quand tous les
autres parlent de leur petite réforme
que la gauche est disséqué façon puce le
que la droite se cherche une colonne
vertébrale entre ceux voulant rejoindre
le président de la république par le
choix de la raison parce que c'est la
raison de leur engagement ce qui a été
le nôtre en l'occurrence ya maintenant
quelques années et ceux qui se posent la
question de du baiser de la mort avec
une droite qui n'est absolument pas une
droite républicaine selon moi qui n'ai
pas une droite qui se retrouvent dans
les valeurs de la république dont on
parlait tout à l'heure et qui est celle
d'eric zemmour qui est celle de marine
le pen jacques chirac a toujours mis un
cordon sanitaire ce cordon sanitaire il
n'a jamais été aussi près de 2,2 de
casser je trouve ça inquiétant je trouve
ça grave un habitant d'orsay qui avait
que courilleau a lancé un nouveau groupe
de réflexion à l'échelle nationale
intitulée handicap république et société
le jeune homme de 27 ans veut placer les
questions liées au handicap au coeur de
la campagne présidentielle pour le
moment ce n'est malheureusement pas le
cas un document d'une vingtaine de pages
expose 30 propositions dont les
candidats sont invités à à s'emparer
pierrick ou rio vous le connaissez bien
bâti un habitant dorsenne ans un ami
faisait partie de votre lien a mis hors
série s qui était mon collins est liée à
orsay rang en 2020 il a été le colistier
d'amylin montchalin en 2021 aux
élections régionales et il a porté les
couleurs d'agir plus que dignement
aujourd'hui lance ce mouvement dont vous
avez parlé où ils formulent des
propositions qui sont d'ailleurs entre
parenthèses très intéressante et je
trouve que c'est une c'est une très
bonne chose c'est une très bonne
initiative je le félicite je vous invite
à poursuivre et j'espère que ça
permettra en effet que le débat sur le
handicap ne soient pas traités là encore
par dessus l'épaule comme on a pu
l'entendre dans des récentes polémiques
certains candidats à l'élection
présidentielle mais bel et bien de façon
concrète et sur le long terme là encore
le gouvernement a avancé c'est une
discussion que j'ai souvent lu avec avec
pierrick courilleau peut-être pas assez
loin ce afin qu'une revalorisation 100
euros par mois de l'allocation pour les
personnes handicapées il faut aller plus
loin et c'est vrai que si pierrick
courilleau bon vous savez moi je vois le
calvaire qui est le sien chaque jour
quand il doit se déplacer quand il doit
entreprendre tout un tas de démarches
administratives aujourd'hui faut
faciliter la vie énormément de toutes
les personnes qui sont touchées par le
handicap ça concerne quasiment 12
millions de personnes en france c'est
pas une quantité négligeable et ça doit
pas être traité comme tel donc je suis
pour tout à fait que ce soit au centre
de la campagne présidentielle mais la
campagne présidentielle c'est l'échelon
de plus haut mais ça doit aussi être
traité à l'échelon le plus local qui est
celui aujourd'hui voilà delà de la delà
de l'adaptabilité de nos villes aux
personnes à mobilité réduite mais pas qu
aux personnes malvoyantes aux personnes
malentendantes
et à toutes formes de handicap puisque
comme on le sait et c'est pas un lieu
commun le dire tous les handicaps ne se
voit pas donc il faut absolument
remettre au centre des discussions
les propositions sur le handicap et le
fascicule qu'assortie pierrick ou rio
est en tout cas un très bon début pour
pour commencer à
réfléchir à toutes ces politiques à
mettre en place vous êtes déjà lancé
dans la campagne des législatives dans
votre circonscription la cinquième de
l'essonne comment se déroule la campagne
pour l'instant est ce que ce n'est pas
pour l'instant un peu enfin dur
d'imposer des thèmes de législatives
alors qu'on est en pleine présidentielle
moi j'ai voulu débuter cette campagne
législative très tôt parce que je
voulais avoir le temps d'écouter parce
que je voulais avoir le temps de
rencontrer je voulais avoir le temps de
faire les choses bien c'est vrai que
c'est une élection qui surgit quelques
semaines après les élections
présidentielles et j'ai voulu prendre ce
temps j'ai voulu avoir le temps de faire
infuser les réflexions de co construire
avec les habitants un programme local
qui soit en phase avec leurs
interrogations avec leurs problématiques
et c'est pour ça que depuis quelques
mois maintenant on sillonne les villes
de la circonscription à la rencontre des
habitants aujourd'hui on est dans un
temps c'est vrai qu'il est plus
présidentiel et donc sur des thématiques
qui sont plus nationale mais les
thématiques nationales elle se répercute
au local donc on fait les deux en même
temps j'ai envie de dire mais la
priorité aujourd'hui c'est les élections
présidentielles parce que c'est la plus
prochaine échéance demain il faudra
parler de législatives il faudra sortir
un programme il y aura des étiquettes de
partis politiques qui seront mises sur
la table et à ce moment là la course
sera véritablement lancée
pour l'instant on reste sur une
dynamique de deux présidentielles avec
un presque candidat président de la
république et au derrière lequel au sein
de la maison commune nous sommes tous
engagés et demain il faudra aller
traiter les autres sujets dont je vous
parlais votre circonscription c'est
celle du plateau de saclay un projet
ambitieux s'y prépare au cas où devenir
le plus gros classeurs scientifique du
monde ce projet aura des incidences sur
la vasière territoire troisième c'est
important il faut déjà anticiper les
futurs besoins pour l'avenir quelle est
votre vision pour ce site aride
territoires stratégiques
la vision elle est très claire là encore
il faut regarder demain et il faut que
toutes les générations se mettent autour
de la table c'est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure vous parlez la jeunesse c'est
définitivement le projet de la jeunesse
paris saclay paris saclay c'est ce que
j'ai appelé la génération paris saclay
elle a des choses à dire parce que c'est
elle qui va utiliser ce plateau demain
dans le dix ans dans 20 ans dans trente
ans dans 40 ans et donc elle a des
choses à dire la clé pour moi de la
réussite de ce projet c'est les
mobilités aujourd'hui tout le monde est
unanime pour dire qu'il faut réinventer
la façon de se déplacer on peut plus que
prendre son véhicule personnel on ne
peut plus que prendre les transports en
commun on ne peut pas que prendre son
vélo on ne peut pas que prendre
l'autobus il faut avoir un véritable
maillage complémentaire de toutes ces
façons de se déplacer et on doit mettre
ça en place les mobilités c'est le sujet
numéro un de la réussite du plateau de
saclay j'en suis absolument convaincu
aujourd'hui ça s'articule pour moi
autour de quatre moyens principaux que
sont le ring des ulis qui est en train
d'être refait par le département de
l'essonne pour désenclaver ce noeud
routier infernal du matin au soir un dif
et le et fluidifier le trafic sur la
n118 sur laquelle on peut pas faire une
voie de transport en commun en site
propre tcsp la deuxième c'est évidemment
le rer b qui doit être rénové et ça doit
faire partie intégrante du projet de
l'état il faut réussir à obtenir la
rénovation du rer b est dans le cadre de
cette opération d'intérêt national parce
que c'est l'enjeu premier troisièmement
c'est la ligne 18 du métro qui ira de
orly en passant par le plateau de saclay
jusqu'à versailles et ensuite de
versailles jusqu'à
la défense nanterre et après plus loin
lorsque c'est là c'est une des seules
façons aujourd'hui de de pouvoir se
déplacer sur le plateau et enfin un
téléphérique qui est un projet qui date
pas d'aujourd'hui le général de gaulle
en parlait déjà en 1964 du téléphérique
sur le plateau c'est pour ça qu'on avait
installé à chaud c'est au niveau de ce
plateau ça devait être desservie par un
téléphérique et ce téléphérique il irait
de courtaboeuf en passant par orsay en
remontant sur le plateau et ensuite en
longeant la 118 jusqu'au pont de sèvres
c'est déjà le cas d'ailleurs sur cette
partie là des hauts-de-seine et sur une
partie des yvelines il est en train
d'être lancée et donc c'est un véritable
maillage complémentaires qui fera qu'on
pourra se déplacer demain évidemment des
pistes cyclables et évidemment des
chemins de randonnée pédestre et on
puisse se déplacer de façon douce comme
on dit sur sur ce plateau mais ces deux
plateaux que son courtaboeuf et le
plateau de saclay avec une vallée au
milieu avec des villes qui s'appelle ben
hur et or s'est notamment ils doivent
être liés ils doivent être liés c'est
une impérieuse nécessité parce que vous
avez d'un côté la plus grosse zone
d'activité économique d'europe qui
courtaboeuf et de l'autre côté le
plateau de saclay où on a l'ambition de
construire le troisième kloster
international d'innovation de recherche
et donc on doit avoir les moyens de nos
ambitions ça c'est une c'est une
évidence or c'est la quatrième ville de
france entre 10000 et 20000 habitants où
il fait bon vivre soyez moins un
classement national d'action villes et
villages où il fait bon vivre publié
dans le jdd ce mois ci une fierté pour
vous en tant qu'élu j'imagine que votre
ville soit reconnue c'est un cadre de
vie qui est privilégiée orsay on est au
coeur de la vallée de chevreuse c'est
une ville qui est très cher à mon coeur
j'y ai grandi j'y suis élu
aujourd'hui on a ce classement qui est
sorti dans le jdd c'est un petit peu
l'arbre qui cache la forêt quand même on
a quand même énormément de choses alors
vous allez me dire que le mieux est
l'ennemi du bien eh ben ça tombe bien on
veut faire mieux et bien c'est le tête
ça a été toute la raison de la
candidature que j'ai menée avec mon
équipe à orsay en 2020 quand on parle de
sécurité on est encore une des seules
villes qu'ils n'installent pas de vidéo
protection pour des problématiques qui
sont éminemment politique avec des
écologistes
de papier qui d écologie de circonstance
qui refusent dogmatiquement qu'on puisse
davantage protéger nos habitants alors
qu'ils aient jamais eu autant de
cambriolages qui ait jamais eu autant
d'insécurité qui a jamais eu autant
d'agressions dans les rues ou de
commerces vandalisés on parle de
fiscalité on a une augmentation
substantielle de la fiscalité il ya une
dizaine d'années maintenant dans les or
c'est un pays encore aujourd'hui le
tribut on a une urbanisation dans la
vallée qui est absolument folle avec un
projet de centre ville ubuesque là ou
encore nous on avait fait des
propositions qui s'inscrit véritablement
dans une logique environnementale avec
un projet de place publique de lieux dé
change de lieu de partage avec des
écologistes qu entre parenthèses on
n'entend pas beaucoup non le
centre-ville en recevra le dossier merci
beaucoup lui le roi d'avoir interdit
rappelle que vous êtes le président
d'agir en essonne et nous on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
numéro de l'hebdo politique très bonne
soirée à tous sur à 200 ha sur
les photos politique